thema rüstungsausgaben wird jetzt hier
auch wichtig sein denn jetzt geht es um
das bundeswehr sondervermögens gesetz
beziehungsweise erst einmal um die
änderung des grundgesetzes denn um
dieses sondervermögen von 100 milliarden
euro
einzurichten hat sich die
bundesregierung entschieden eine
änderung im grundgesetz festzuschreiben
da hat sie ja auch auf die unterstützung
der union gesetzt denn um das
grundgesetz zu ändern braucht ist eine
zwei-drittel-mehrheit hier im parlament
da gab es noch sehr viele diskussionen
darüber aber man hat sich dann anfang
dieser woche darauf geeinigt hat der
sogenannte formulierungshilfe
noch einmal
formuliert die koalitionsparteien
cdu/csu in dem unter anderem jetzt zum
beispiel noch mal geklärt wurde ob das
sondervermögen dieser 100 milliarden
euro zusätzlich zu einem
verteidigungshaushalte kommen der dann
ja irgendwann auch dass zwei prozent
ziel der nato erreichen soll oder ob
dieses
sondervermögen dazu beiträgt und man hat
sich nun eigentlich ist trägt dazu bei
näheres nichts vom finanzminister
der angriff russlands auf die ukraine
markiert eine zäsur
eine zäsur
die historischen charakter hat denn in
europa kämpfen nun zwei mitglieder der
völkergemeinschaft zwei
völkerrechtssubjekt nach diesen und
provozierten angriff zum ersten mal seit
dem zweiten weltkrieg wieder
gegeneinander
der bundeskanzler hat dieses zeitenwende
genannt und hat für die bundesregierung
angekündigt dass wir die fähigkeit zur
landes- und bündnisverteidigung
wieder stärken müssen ich bin sicher
diese zeitenwende in der wir gegenwärtig
stehen die wird im nachhinein einmal im
zusammenhang betrachtet werden mit der
entscheidung deutschlands zur
wiederbewaffnung zum eintritt in unserer
westlichen
verteidigungsbündnis dem nato
doppelbeschluss und wir als koalition
von spd bündnis 90/die grünen und freien
demokraten wir stellen uns unserer
historischen verantwortung
der minister einen moment bitte
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen dies ist
eine wirklich wichtige debatte ich will
nicht sagen dass andere nicht wichtig
sind aber es ist schon eine wesentliche
sache das grundgesetz zu ändern und ich
bitte sie daher wenn sie unterhaltung
oder wichtige themen haben gehen sie
bitte raus und ansonsten setzten sie
sich bitte auf ihre plätze und stellen
sie die unterhaltung hier im saal ein
vielen dank
bitteschön
vielen dank frau präsidentin wir haben
in deutschland lange von einer
friedensdividende profitiert als man
glaubte das ende der geschichte sei
erreicht wir lernen aber neu frieden und
freiheit und auch unserer wohlstand
frieden freiheit und unser wohlstand das
ist nichts was wir von der generation
der der brandt und schmidt und kohl und
genscher scherben frieden und freiheit
und auch unser wohlstand sie müssen in
jeder generation neu begründet und neu
erreicht werden
es ist nicht mehr die zeit für eine
friedensdividende sondern wir müssen
unsere bündnis und
verteidigungsfähigkeit stärken dieser
sonderfonds ich sage sonderfonds weil
sondervermögen ein technischer begriff
ist er ja viele eingeladen hat zu
ironischen bemerkungen dieser sonderform
ja er wird jetzt auch mit
kreditermächtigungen aufgestellt die
alternativen wären wirtschaftlich in
dieser kritischen phase schlechter
deshalb schlagen wir vor ein
sondervermögen das grundgesetz
aufzunehmen um diese historischen
aufgabe gerecht zu werden
damit
damit verbinden zugleich aber auch den
respekt vor den soldatinnen und soldaten
denn es geht ja nicht nur um
militärisches
großgerät geht nicht nur um
investitionen in große vorhaben sondern
es geht auch um die persönlichen
ausrüstungsgegenstände der soldatinnen
und soldaten die sich hier oben den
vorsitzenden des deutschen
bundeswehrverbandes herrn wüster und
andere und ich will ihnen sagen
stellvertretend für ihre kameradinnen
und kameraden
dieses parlament ist sich auch seiner
verantwortung für unsere uniform
trägerinnen und uniformträger bewusst
wer für unser land nötigenfalls sogar
mit einsatz des eigenen lebens wirkt der
verdient die rückenstärkung des ganzen
deutschen bundestags
ihre kolleginnen und kollegen ich danke
den koalitionsfraktionen für die sehr
guten beratungen aber ich danke
ausdrücklich auch der cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion für die guten
gespräche die wir geführt haben
insbesondere mit alexander dobrindt und
andreas middelberg die beiden
federführend für die union tätig waren
haben wir viel zeit verbracht aber auch
gutes erreicht ich weiß es gab auch
andere vorstellungen es gab die
vorstellung man könnte noch einmal eine
ausnahme von der schuldenbremse machen
den artikel 115 nutzen das wäre nicht
klug gewesen denn wir würden dadurch die
schuldenbremse insgesamt in ihrer
wirkung in frage stellen deshalb wollten
wir dem nicht folgen und auf ein
neuerlicher solidaritätszuschlag zur
finanzierung der stärkung der bundeswehr
wäre nicht ratsam
verteilungspolitisch nicht wenn man doch
kleine und mittlere einkommen nicht
belasten sollte und allen und allerdings
auch nicht in einer situation der
inflation und wo wir wirtschaftliche
erholung brauchen deshalb ist es richtig
es über dieses sondervermögen zu machen
ohne soli und ohne aufweichung der
schuldenbremse insgesamt
es steht also
es steht also gewissermaßen neben der
schuldenbremse jetzt dieses
sondervermögen was im umkehrschluss
bedeutet für alle anderen
wünschenswerten und sinnvollen vorhaben
gilt die schuldenbremse und damit die
notwendigkeit der politischen
priorisierung mein letzter gedanke die
gespräche haben wir geführt in meinem
ministerium dem ehemaligen
reichsluftfahrtministerium
und ist das nicht nicht eine besondere
note der geschichte wir haben dem
reichsten ehemaligen
reichsluftfahrtministerium
verhandelt über ein sondervermögen für
die bundeswehr in diesen räumen wurde
vor jahrzehnten der aggressive
militarismus deutschlands vorangetrieben
damals wurde deutschlands militärische
stärke in europa gefürchtet heute wird
in europa befürchtet dass deutschland
militärische defizite hat und genau das
an diesem historischen ort haben wir
gemeinsam beendet
bundesfinanzminister christian lindner
hier zu anfang dieser debatte auch
nochmal mit historischen vergleich und
es ist ja auch immer historisch wenn das
grundgesetz geändert werden muss auch
deswegen braucht es die zwei drittel
mehrheit im bundestag
meine lieben kolleginnen und kollegen
das ist heute ein guter tag für die
bündnis und verteidigungsfähigkeit in
deutschland in europa und auch für die
bundeswehr man möchte vielleicht
einerseits aussagen dass das leider so
ist weil diese zäsur ukraine krieg ist
in gewisser weise auch ein
erweckungserlebnis aber es ist in jedem
fall ein notwendiger und wichtiger
schritt den wir heute tun dass wir diese
verteidigungsfähigkeit unseres landes
und in europa wirklich wieder herstellen
und die bundeswehr stark machen wir
stellen 100 milliarden extra für die
bundeswehr zur verfügung
in einer sonder schuld das muss man auch
ehrlich sagen ich danke wie der
bundesfinanzminister allen beteiligten
an den gesprächen ausdrücklich ich
glaube es war am ende fruchtbare und
gute gespräche jedenfalls haben die nach
unserer einschätzung ein gutes ergebnis
hervorgebracht
die 100 milliarden stehen
vollumfänglich der bundeswehr zur
verfügung sie stehen nicht irgendwelchen
sicherheits zwecken zur verfügung und
das ist auch richtig so wir schätzen die
aufgabe etwa der cyber sicherheit auch
als sehr sehr wichtig ein sie ist aber
eine aufgabe die viele ressourcen
überspannt die eine daueraufgabe auch
für die nächsten jahre ist und wie nicht
speziell das adressiert was uns jetzt
hier zum handeln zwingt zum handeln
zwingt uns das was auch der
bundesfinanzminister eben erwähnt hat
wir müssen wieder zurück in ein szenario
der möglichen landesverteidigung das
haben wir über viele jahre
vernachlässigt das haben wir nicht mehr
im blick gehabt und dieses szenario der
landesverteidigung müssen wir wieder
herstellen und das erfordert ist die
mitte zu 100 prozent auf die bundeswehr
zu konzentrieren
und ich will auch deutlich sagen für uns
als union war es ganz wichtig dass wir
uns auch mit der frage befassen dass wir
jetzt nicht einmal 100 milliarden
investieren und danach ist dann schluss
sondern für uns war ganz wichtig die
frage was passiert nach auslaufen des
sondervermögens und deswegen haben wir
auch darauf gedrängt dass dieses
errichtungs gesetz das das
sondervermögen errichtet ausgebaut wird
in seinem regelungsgegenstand auch zu
einem bundeswehr finanzierungsgesetz
über das auslaufen des sondervermögens
hinaus das ist jetzt so
regelungsgegenstand geworden und wir
haben uns in diesem bundeswehr
finanzierungsgesetz darauf verständigt
dass wir zukünftig die finanziellen
mittel bereitstellen wollen um die nato
fähigkeit ziele zu erreichen ich glaube
das ist ein ganz ganz wichtiger schritt
den wir zusätzlich in diesen
verhandlungen erreicht haben und darüber
sollten wir eigentlich alle froh sein
ich will die weiteren punkte
wirtschaftsplan unterausschuss
bildungszeit punkt den wir konkret
bestimmt haben ich will die einzelnen
punkte nicht im einzelnen noch einmal
ansprechen aber was mir auch wichtig ist
weil das in den letzten debatten in den
letzten wochen in der generaldebatte
oder auch in der ersten debatte die wir
hier zum sondervermögen hatten weil das
so angesprochen wurde wir haben jetzt 16
jahre regierungsverantwortung der union
gehabt um die union hat die bundeswehr
heruntergefahren und die union ist
gewissermaßen an dem zustand von heute
schuld das vereinfacht glaube ich den
blickwinkel sehr wenn man mal wenn man
mal die letzten 23 jahre passieren lässt
dann hat in den letzten 23 jahren haben
neunzehn jahre die sozialdemokraten
mitregiert sieben jahre führend und
zwölf jahre mit uns
zwischendurch war auch die fdp mit
verantwortlich das darf man auch offen
sagen die fdp ist auch nicht
hervorgetreten mit anregungen zur
steigerung des verteidigungsetats
was mir aber wichtig ist ist schon noch
der hinweis weil sie da immer sehr
vereinfachend argumentiert der
bundesfinanzminister der jetzige
bundeskanzler hat in der letzten periode
als wir gemeinsam in der großen
koalition regiert hat in seiner
finanzplanung vom sommer 20 21 eine
planung vorgelegt die einen stetig
sinkenden verteidigungsetats
20 25 vorgesehen hat also ich sag das
mal sehr deutlich
beiträge der sozialdemokraten zur
steigerung der bemühungen aus der zeit
sind uns eben auch nicht bekannt das
muss man mal sehr genau um auch ehrlich
sagen
und wenn man hier über einzelne projekte
spricht und ich kann mich noch sehr gut
an die auseinandersetzungen im letzten
wahlkampf erinnern als auch etwa von dem
einsatz bewacht oder der anschaffung
bewaffneter drohnen die rede war dann
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen ist mir
nicht erinnerlich dass die
sozialdemokraten daher vor getreten
hervorgetreten werden mit besonderen
bemühen diese dinge zu beschleunigen und
überhaupt ins werk zu setzen sondern da
ist uns eher innerlich dass die
bemühungen von annegret kramp
karrenbauer aufgehalten wurden durch den
damaligen bundesfinanzminister um das
mal sehr deutlich zu sagen
also hier tragen und ich sage das ganz
offen wir tragen
unseren teil der verantwortung und den
tragen wir auch tatsächlich aber ich
glaube hier sollte sich keiner im haus
groß brüsten und sagen wir sind aber
hier die nehmen gewesen die in den
letzten jahren mit besonderen bemühungen
hervorgetreten werden um die bundeswehr
in diesem land zu stärken das sage ich
ganz offen und da sollten wir uns wenn
wir in dieser frage jetzt dieses
sondervermögen auf den weg zu bringen
wenn wir uns in dieser frage einig sind
dann sollten wir auch in der
retrospektive vielleicht ein bisschen
jetzt abrüsten was die gegenseitigen
schuldzuweisungen an geht darum geht es
mir sage ich ganz ausdrücklich heute auf
wir sollten wenn wir diesen weg der
einigkeit gehen heute nicht jede minute
dazu nutzen um uns gegenseitig die dinge
vorzuhalten in dem sinne danke ich noch
mal allen beteiligten ich glaube wir
haben ein sehr gutes ergebnis erreicht
für dieses lang für europa für unsere
bundeswehr herzlichen dank
sagte stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der
unionsfraktion und nun wird die
bundesverteidigungsministerium sprechen
aber zunächst einmal
sie werden jetzt noch mal die letzten
minuten aufgerufen zu der abstimmung zum
haushalt und nun kommt aber christine
lambrecht
bundesverteidigungsministerium
auch präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren zeitenwende zäsur
historischer tag das sind die begriffe
die fallen im zusammenhang mit dieser
grundgesetzänderung und sie sind richtig
denn es ist genauso groß ist ein
historischer tag denn wir beschließen
heute ein ertüchtigung paket wie es noch
nie gegeben hat in der geschichte der
bundeswehr 100 milliarden euro
sondervermögen das ist viel geld aber es
ist gut investiert nämlich in sicherheit
und frieden unseres landes
und wir müssen angesichts des brutalen
angriffs tricks russland auch die
ukraine doch uns der tatsache stellen
dass sicherheit ihren preis hat und dass
wir auch in der lage sein müssen unsere
werte militärisch zu verteidigen das ist
ins bewusstsein gekommen und das ist
richtig dass wir daraus dann die
entsprechenden konsequenzen ziehen meine
damen über jahrzehnte wurde die
bundeswehr vernachlässigt und
heruntergewirtschaftet und es hat große
lücken insbesondere in der ausrüstung
gerissen und meine damen und herren ich
treffe überall wenn ich gespräche führe
auch zu hoch motivierte soldatinnen und
soldaten die mit ganz viel engagement
unserem land dienen und ja deswegen
möchte ich auch an ober- ist höchst nach
recht herzlich begrüßen den vorsitzenden
des bundeswehrverbandes des deutschen
bundeswehrverbandes vier stellvertretend
quasi für diese engagierten soldatinnen
und soldaten meine damen und herren
mit ganz viel kreativität jetzt da das
kompensiert was oftmals nicht vorhanden
ist denn ich höre ganz oft wir haben das
nicht wir haben davon zu wenig es ist
verbraucht es ist es defekt und damit
muss endlich schluss sein und heute
leben wir dafür den grundstein meine
damen und herren das mit dieser
mangelverwaltung schluss ist gestärkt
und die bundeswehr unsere streitkräfte
so aus dass sie ihren kernauftrag
endlich in vollem umfang erfüllen können
nämlich die landes- und
bündnisverteidigung
darum geht es und das schulden wir
zuallererst unseren soldatinnen und
soldaten denn sie sind es die unseren
frieden verteidigen unsere freiheit
unsere demokratie und sie sind es die im
ernstfall unter einsatz von leib und
leben für uns kämpfen und deswegen ist
eine ordentliche mindestausstattung eine
ausstattung das mindeste und deshalb
müssen wir auch dafür sorgen dass das
sondervermögen so schnell wie möglich
bei ihnen ankommt denn jede aktive
soldaten und jeder aktive soldat bekommt
jetzt endlich die volle schutzausrüstung
vom helm bis zur kampf begleitung und
das schon
2025 und nicht wie vormals geplant erst
20 31 in solchen fristen wurde geplant
und damit muss schluss sein meine damen
und herren und der verschuldet es auf
unseren verbündeten in der nato
in der eu und zwar gerade jetzt wo putin
die europäische friedensordnung
zertrümmerter wir stehen ganz fest an
der seite unserer verbündeten an der
ostflanke in liter und der slowakei und
auf der ostsee und wir werden da sein
wenn diese aufgaben weiter wachsen und
wir wollen unsere bundeswehr zu einem
europäischen kräfte verstärker machen in
der nato und in der eu zu einer allround
armee die ein starker militärischer
kooperations und anlehnung partner ist
damit zeigen dir wie ernst es uns ist
meine damen und herren und wie ernst es
uns ist das haben wir auch in diesem
dieser grundgesetzänderung
beziehungsweise in dem begleitpaket
beschlossen dass wir uns auch
langfristig zu der nato zielen bekennen
auch das ist ganz wichtig für unsere
verbündeten dass sie sich auch
langfristig auf uns verlassen können
deswegen war es wichtig auch über das
sondervermögen heraus hinaus diese
entscheidung und diese erklärung
abzugeben und wie ernst es uns ist das
zeigt aber auch der blick auf unseren
wirtschaftsplan und die vorhabenliste zu
diesem sonderfall bilden da möchte ich
an der stelle ein herzliches dankeschön
all den mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
im ministerium aussprechen die da
wirklich eine wird eine eine
unglaubliche leistung erbracht haben
beim aufstellen da bin ich insbesondere
dem generalinspekteur sehr dankbar denn
wir haben etwas gemacht was vielleicht
viele verwirrt hat wir haben nicht die
listen der industrie die uns zu hauf
zugesandt wurden zur grundlage für
diesen wirtschaftsplan und zur grundlage
für diese vorhabens liste gemacht
sondern das was wir wirklich brauchen um
die herausforderungen auch entsprechend
angehen zu können deswegen haben viele
auch darauf gewartet frühzeitig diese
liste diesem wirtschaftsplan und diesen
vorhabens plan zu bekommen aber uns war
es wichtig zuerst zu identifizieren was
brauchen wir denn und es dann eben auch
entsprechend festzuschreiben und ich
weiß wie gesagt der eine der andere er
hätte sich gewünscht hätte darauf
vielleicht auch aus wahlkreis interessen
früher einfluss nehmen können aber nein
es geht darum klar festzuschreiben was
ist notwendig für die bundeswehr und das
auch in einem solchen plan
festzuschreiben denn es geht darum
die
führungsfähigkeit die führungsfähigkeit
sicherzustellen zum beispiel durch
funkgeräte damit endlich die bundeswehr
mit anderen nationen wenn wir da im
einsatz sind dann auch entsprechend
kommunizieren könnte es war die ganze
zeit nicht möglich das darf nicht mehr
länger sein schluss mit der mangel
verwaltet mit der mangelverwaltung bei
der persönlichen ausstattung schluss mit
der mangelverwaltung bei all den
bereichen wie nachtsichtgeräten das
gehört jetzt der vergangenheit an meine
damen und herren
und ganz wichtig war uns bei diesen
sondervermögen dass wir eben nicht nicht
zu lasten anderer ressorts jetzt sparen
müssen dass wir diese verantwortung
annehmen die bundeswehr auszustatten
aber nicht bei anderen ressorts
einsparen deswegen bin ich auch dankbar
dass wir genau diesen weg gewählt haben
dass es eben nicht dazu kommt dass
gerade in dieser schwierigen zeit
wichtige projekte wird die geld da sein
muss dass die angehalten oder
eingeschränkt werden müssten sondern
dass wir eben beides beide
herausforderungen annehmen können das
sind wir auch den bürgerinnen und bürger
in diesem land schuldet bei der damen
und herren es wird sich viel verändern
in den letzten wochen und monaten denn
das muss jetzt auch umgesetzt werden das
muss ganz schnell bei der truppe
ankommen und es wird auch so geschehen
und dazu gehört dann auch dass das
beschaffungswesen deutlich verändert
werden muss da ist richtig viel zu tun
wir haben die ersten weichen schon
gestellt 20 prozent aller aufträge in
der bundeswehr müssen nicht mehr mit
einem bürokratischen vergabeverfahren
ausgeschrieben werden können freihändig
vergeben werden wir nutzen die
möglichkeiten die uns das europäische
vergaberecht gibt davon abzuweichen auch
damit dass es eben schneller geht
dann noch viele änderungen folgen und
wir haben die möglichkeit durch einen
vorschlag den ich vorgelegt habe jetzt
noch vor der sommerpause auch eine
beschleunigung zu beschließen eine
weitere beschleunigung zu beschließen
meine damen und herren das ist wichtig
damit wir deutlich machen dieses viele
geld wird richtig eingesetzt effizient
effektiv eingesetzt das ist unsere
aufgabe und wir nehmen sie auf jeden
fall an wir können heute ein zeichen der
geschlossenheit setzen an unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten unsere
verbündeten und an die menschen in
unserem land wir stehen zu unserer
verantwortung für sicherheit für frieden
freiheit und demokratie vielen dank
bundesverteidigungsminister von
christina lambrecht war das hat hier
auch nochmal dieses sondervermögen
verteidigt es ist viel geld kaum
vorstellbar eine zahl mit elf nullen und
gleichzeitig es wird seit jahren ja
schon immer wieder auf die probleme in
der bundeswehr aufmerksam gemacht auf
personalmangel und auch
unvollständige ausstattung sogar
schutzwesten fehlen manchmal jacken und
unterwäsche
peter böhringer auf die fraktion
jetzt geht es wieder
herr böhringer ich bitte sie um
verständnis ich möchte nur bekannt geben
dass sich jetzt die namentliche
abstimmung schließe und die
schriftführerin und schriftführer bitte
mit der auszählung zu beginnen und das
ergebnis wird ihn später bekannt gegeben
und jetzt haben sie das wort herr
pühringer bitte schön danke frau
präsidentin union spd fdp und grüne
haben seit jahrzehnten regiert das
ergebnis ist dass die bundeswehr nur
noch bedingt einsatzbereit ist
20 jahre nichtstun also der altparteien
20 jahre investitionsstau bei der
bundeswehr die afg hatte all das seit
jahren kritisiert
und nun stellen sie sich häuten und
wollen in einem parlamentarischen
schweinsgalopp über eine präzedenzlosen
grundgesetzänderung geld bereitstellen
die vorgelegten gesetze zur ausrüstung
der bundeswehr sind natürlich in der
materiellen absicht begrüßenswerte doch
dieser weg über die grundgesetzänderung
ist der falsche die verfassung wird
missbraucht wenn man eine konkrete
budgetzahlen hineinschreibt und ohne not
einen nebenhaushalt begründet so etwas
macht man nicht völlig ungeachtet des
ziels und
ganz explizit in richtung medien es ist
einfach nicht korrekt dass die 100
milliarden euro für die bundeswehr
projekte nur mit einer änderung des
grundgesetzes möglich sind warum auch
vor februar 22 jährige nie jemand auch
nur auf die idee einer solchen
konstruktion gekommen sie ist materiell
und gesetzgeberisch zur zielerreichung
schlicht überflüssig
das sondervermögens soll dem artikel 87a
grundgesetz abgesichert werden eine
eigene kreditermächtigung bekommen und
von der schuldenbremse ausgenommen seien
so etwas ist im haushalt völlig ohne
beispiel seit 1949 es gibt heute bereits
15 sondervermögen den bundeshaushalt
kein einziges davon wurde im grundgesetz
verankert
diese grundgesetzänderung wäre haushalts
und verfassungsrechtlich einen dammbruch
künftig wäre damit der weg frei für
analoge sonder schulden konstrukte für
beliebige andere ausgabe wünsche zum
beispiel wäre ein 200 milliarden euro
klima sondervermögen außerhalb des
regulären haushalts denkbar damit wäre
kein einheitlicher haushalt ohne
dauerhaft über das grundgesetz fixierte
neben haushaltspositionen mehr
aufstellbar absurde ironie am rande
sozialpolitik etwa könnte künftig
weiterhin der schuldenbremse unterliegen
diverse ideologie positionen aber nicht
die heutige grundgesetzänderung braucht
die koalition nur um die schuldenbremse
zu umgehen das ist der einzige grund in
unserem änderungsantrag haben wir
mehrere alternative wege zum 100
milliarden ziel aufgezeigt ohne
vergewaltigung der verfassung
die zusätzlichen bundeswehr mittel von
etwa 20 milliarden euro pro jahr über
die nächsten fünf jahre die sie heute
hier beschließen wollen die gehören ganz
einfach regulär im kernhaushalt
eingestellt alleine nur im 22er italien
der eben von ein paar minuten
verabschiedet haben hatten wir als afd
einsparmöglichkeiten von über 160
milliarden euro aufgezeigt man muss
einmal einfach bei anfang an klima und
transformation sie die logi zu sparen
dann geht das auch
ganz übel noch die fraktion planen
ernsthaft die afg aus der
parlamentarischen kontrolle der 100
milliarden dauerhaft fern zu halten das
ist kein schlechter witz der
gesetzentwurf sieht das sieht statt
einem proportional besetzten
kontrollgremium einen wahlmodus
einzelner genehmer personen vor wir
kennen solche waren bestens von etwa 100
anläufen bei der nichtwahl von half die
vize-präsidentin ausschussvorsitz
kandidaten und diverser weiterer gremien
gut des bundestags der entsprechende
paragraf ist ein demokratischer skandal
dass sollten an der wiso wir sollen in
der wahrnehmung unserer
parlamentarischen kontrollrechte
gehindert werden so beerdigt man die
parlamentarische demokratie
fazit das ist überflüssig und so nicht
zustimmungsfähig es braucht keine
grundgesetzänderung um der bundeswehr
ihre investitionsgelder zu geben ich
wiederhole dass in richtung medien es
braucht diese grundgesetzänderung nicht
um der bundeswehr ihre
investitionsgelder zu geben berichten
sie das richtig und korrekt ich sage das
in richtung regierungspartei in richtung
justizministerin in richtung
verteidigungsministerin auch nochmal es
braucht diese grundgesetzänderung nicht
um der bundeswehr ihr geld zu geben wir
zeigen müssen wie er sage ich mich am
antrag wie die bundeswehr auch ohne
diesen verfassungs missbraucht
einsatzfähig ausgerüstet werden kann
ändern sie das und bestimmen so vorzug
danke
angesichts der politischen lager
betrifft dieses sondervermögen natürlich
verschiedene ressorts und so spricht
jetzt auch schon die dritte ministerin
hier in der debatte annalena baerbock
bundes außenministerin
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen am 24 februar
sind wir in einer anderen welt
aufgewacht und in den 100 tagen seit dem
ist unsere welt nicht besser sondern
noch brutaler geworden neben dem
vernichtungskrieg gehen wir jetzt im
donbass erleben müssen 10 wir zeitgleich
einen russischen korn krieg und vor
allen dingen fatale folgen weltweit in
den ärmsten länder dieses planeten
russlands brutaler angriffskrieg schafft
so bitter es ist eine neue realität in
europa und ermahnt die sicherheit der
freiheit unseres lebens ist ein teures
ein kostbares gut dass wir jetzt im
zweifel auch militärisch verteidigen
müssen wir haben uns diese welt nicht
ausgesucht aber wir müssen uns dieser
neuen realität stellen das ist der sinn
politischer verantwortung
und gerade in diesen zeiten in denen
alte gewissheiten über bord gehen ist es
umso wichtiger dass wir uns dieser stabs
politischen verantwortung
fraktionsübergreifend stellen daher ist
unsere einigung auf das sondervermögen
auch mehr als nur 100 milliarden euro
für die bundeswehr sie ist auch ausdruck
unserer bündnis und damit auch unserer
europa fähigkeit wenn wir auf harte
sicherheit schauen dann geht es eben
nicht nur allein um deutschland denn wir
sind nicht eine insel mitten in der welt
zum glücklich verteidigung heute und in
der zukunft bedeutet noch viel mehr denn
je kooperative sicherheit
und es ist gut dass deswegen die
bündnisfähigkeit eben nicht aus dem
gesetz gestrichen worden ist sowie die
union das eigentlich ursprünglich wollte
ich fand's ja vorhin ganz süße dobrindt
dass sie so gesagt haben alle haben sich
bewegt nur wir nicht wenn sie das für
ihr ego brauchen bitte schön ich würde
auch lieber vergessen wollen dass sie
eigentlich zwei prozent ins grundgesetz
schreiben wollten oder nur 75
abgeordnete
aber was mich ehrlich gesagt verwundert
hat ja und deswegen habe ich auch so
intensiv gemeinsam mit ihnen diskutiert
und grund dass sie als jahrzehntelange
europapartei das war ja immer das große
und ich fand wirklich beeindruckende
label der union ausgerechnet die
ertüchtigung von partnern bis zur
letzten minute dogmatisch bekämpft haben
das verwundert mich nicht nur ehrlich
gesagt finde ich das nicht sehr
verantwortungsvoll denn die routen jahr
sie rufen ja jetzt auch wieder und zwar
das möchte unterstreichen zurecht ich
sehe das genauso wie sie sie rufen zu
mehr militärischer unterstützung gerade
auch mit unseren bündnispartnern
aber dann sind sie nicht bereit gewesen
eben diese ertüchtigung unserer partner
auch über das sondervermögen
mitzufinanzieren es wäre ein kleiner
betrag gewesen wäre wichtig gewesen und
das kann ich bis zuletzt nicht verstehen
und ehrlich gesagt das sind entscheidet
dann offensichtlich auch mich von ihm
her durch die union von den grünen mir
bricht kein zacken aus der krone zu
sagen ja ich hätte den ursprünglichen
gesetzesentwurf besser gefunden weil er
eben die stabilisierung und
entwicklungshilfe mit beinhaltet und
weil er auch die cyber fähigkeiten mit
beinhaltet man hört es doch an allen
ecken und enden das geben die großen
herausforderungen unserer zeit nicht nur
sind dass raketen oder bomben fallen
können sondern dass die angriffe eben
auch auf krankenhäuser und
versorgungseinrichtungen in zukunft
passieren können jetzt werden wir das
ist der kompromiss eben diese maßnahmen
gemeinsam über das errichtungs gesetz
und über die nächsten haushalt
finanzieren sage aber auch sehr deutlich
dann stehen alle gemeinsam in der
verantwortung weil die sicherheit
braucht eine umfassende sicherheit und
dafür erträgt dieses hohe haus auch für
die nächsten jahrzehnte eine besondere
verantwortung auch
wenn das sondervermögen jetzt aus meiner
sicht weniger wichtig ist ist es nicht
weniger wichtig denn die defizite bei
der bundeswehr sind keine sekunde länger
tragbar analoge funk systeme mit dem
sich unsere soldatinnen und soldaten im
ernstfall nicht zuverlässig verständigen
können 350 puma-schützenpanzer von den
einsatzfähig kind sind und zur
ehrlichkeit gehört wir holen das nach
was jahrelang geben nicht angegangen
worden ist wir reformieren mit diesem
sondervermögen die
verteidigungsministerin hat darauf
hingewiesen eben auch das
beschaffungswesen wir tun das und so
ehrlich müssen sie zu sich selbst dann
sein was zeige der union über lange zeit
nicht wollten nämlich im mittelpunkt
unserer sicherheit die sicherheit der
soldatinnen und soldaten und des
bündnisses zu stellen und eben nicht die
interessen der rüstungsindustrie oder
wer am lautesten ruft da gab es in der
vergangenheit die aktionisten vorgänge
um das hier einmal freundlich zu sagen
puma oder 450 m wurden beschafft ohne
ersatzteile wartungsverträge oder auch
waffen wir werden jetzt in zukunft viel
stärker systeme von der stange kaufen
die auch andere streitkräfte bereits
erprobt haben statt auf teure
eigenentwicklung zu setzen weil das
vielleicht im wahlkreis für die
rüstungsindustrie fahren zu hause ist so
schön ankommt wird es an dieser stelle
eine klare transparenz über das
beschaffungswesen geben und ich glaube
ein bisschen selbstkritik an dieser
stelle wäre angebracht und zeitgleich
ist klar
in dieser neuen herausforderung
reicht eben ein sondervermögen nicht aus
die bündnis verteidigungsfähigkeit ist
weit weit mehr und auch diese fragen
müssen wir gemeinsam angehen und ich
möchte an dieser stelle einmal sehr
deutlich sagen ich kann verstehen dass
einige von ihnen habe ich glaube jeder
von uns und ich glaub wahrscheinlich
alle parteien und fraktionen werden
angesprochen 100 milliarden für die
bundeswehr bei uns im krankenhaus da
fehlen die pflegekräfte bei uns in der
kita sind keine erzieherinnen und
erzieher ich glaube auch dass es die
verantwortung des heutigen tages uns
diesen fragen gemeinsam zu stellen aber
die dürfen soziale gerechtigkeit und
sicherheit jetzt nicht gegeneinander
ausspielen dass 1 mein appell an
diejenigen die noch hadern das
sondervermögen das schafft luft gerade
für andere haushaltstitel ja wir müssen
die erst noch gemeinsam beschließen aber
wir wollen und werden erst gemeinsam tun
und diejenigen die jetzt sagen ich
glaube ich den schlossbau präsident sind
diejenigen die sagen aber das
krankenhaus wurde jetzt nicht besser
finanziert das stimmt aber was wäre es
für ein signal in diesem moment wenn wir
als deutscher bundestag weil wir keine
zwei-drittel-mehrheit hinbekommen jetzt
nein sagen wir sind in einer zeit wo
unsere bündnispartner und brauchen im
baltikum genauso wie im sahel er könne
nicht sagen die kampfhubschrauber sind
weiterhin nicht da ich glaube wir sind
nicht nur in einem historischen moment
bei den alten gebäuden 100 milliarden
euro beschließen sondern wir sind in
einen moment wo deutschland sagt wir
sind da wenn europa uns braucht und
europa braucht uns jetzt mutter
kostbares gut gemeinsam zu schützen die
sicherheit der freiheit unseres lebens
herzlichen kommen
bundesaußenminister in anderen lena
baerbock hat ja noch einmal dafür
geworben dass die abgeordneten dieser
grundgesetzänderung
zustimmen
491 abgeordnete müssen mit ja stimmen
das ist die zweidrittelmehrheit die
notwendig ist in diesem parlament um
hier eine grundgesetzänderung
zu vollziehen dietmar bartsch ist der
nächste redner
für bündnis 90 die grünen über den
gesetzentwurf der bundesregierung
entwurf eines gesetzes über die
feststellung des bundes haushaltsplan
für das haushaltsjahr
2022 haushaltsgesetz
2022 drucksachen 20.000 20.000 2020 1220
1200 120 602 sie können sie auch noch
mal selbst 20 16 04 20 16 05 20 16 06
bis 20 16 12 2010 14 20 16 16 20 16 21
und 20 16 23 bis 20 16 28
abgedankt abgegebene stimmkarten
689 mit ja haben gestimmt
403 mit nein haben gestimmt
285 enthaltungen eine der gesetzentwurf
ist somit angenommen
das ergebnis zum haushaltsgesetz 20 22
den haushalt wurde dann und für dieses
jahr verabschiedet vom deutschen
bundestag und nun spricht auch dietmar
bartsch fraktionsvorsitzender der
linksfraktion
diese kolleginnen kollegen sie wollen
heute mit zweidrittelmehrheit das
grundgesetz ändern sie wollen dass die
aufrüstung der bundeswehr
verfassungsrang bekommt das ist aus
meiner sicht ein historischer fehler
meine fraktion wird geschlossen mit nein
stimmen und der linda sie haben gesagt
wer mit nein stimmt ist gegen die
soldaten was für ein unsinn frau berben
sie haben gesagt nur wer
staatspolitische verantwortung ist
stimmt mit ja nein aus staatspolitischer
verantwortung stimmen wir mit nein aus
staatspolitischer warm werden
seit wochen meine damen und der seit
wochen gibt es eine totale schieflage in
der diskussion militär militär nochmal
militär panzerhaubitzen kaliber größen
das alles spielt eine rolle ich bitte
sie alle um mehr nachdenklichkeit auch
aus historischen gründen meine damen es
ist unbestritten dass überfall auch die
ukraine ist ein brutales verbrechen er
bringt unermessliches leid für die
bürgerinnen und bürger der ukraine
putins krieg verändert das leben in
europa verändert unser leben ja das ist
eine zäsur und liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen meine fraktion stellen
überhaupt nicht in abrede dass die
bundeswehr ihren grundgesetzlichen
auftrag der bündnisse und
landesverteidigung nachkommen muss aber
wenn ihr permanent erzielt wird die
bundeswehr ist vernachlässigt worden was
für ein unsinn von 2014 des hohen 20 ist
der verteidigungsetat von
32,4 milliarden wie kein anderer
gestiegen eben haben wir den etat
verabschiedet 50,4 milliarden kein
anderer hat so eine steigerung das ist
mehr als für bildung für familien für
forschung für wohnung zusammen meine
damen und herren es gab kein kaputt
sparen wenn man derartige steigerung
hatte sie verbreiten einen mythos und
das ist unehrlich und das ist
unverantwortlich meine damen und herren
das problem liegt doch ganz woanders
2011 gab es die reform von de maizière
und der hat gesagt weg von dem was im
grundgesetz steht sondern hin zu
auslandseinsätzen das ist die
eigentliche begründung das war damals
schon nicht verfassungskonform und nach
ihrer logik müsste man eigentlich
zuallererst eine nationale
sicherheitsstrategie haben dann müsste
man verteidigungspolitische richtlinien
haben und dann über finanzen reden und
nicht so wie sie das machen sie mich
brauchen hier das grundgesetz meine
damen und herren die bundeswehr leidet
unter geldmangel sondern unser
steuergeld verbrennung sie haben
unfähigen minister der union und jetzt
von der spd gehabt das ist die ursache
das ist josef missmanagement dort was
könnte man alles mit dem 100 pro portion
woche und sie haben doch auch ein herz
für kinder und wollen gegen kinderarmut
agiert warum gibt es nicht da ein
sondervermögen zur bekämpfung von
kinderarmut wir könnten eines der besten
bildungssysteme der welt haben werden
wir das geld einsetzen würde das wäre
notwendig aber anstatt rentner und
familien wirkungsvoll zu entlasten
werden die normalbürger mit diesen 100
milliarden blick und es ist kein die im
anschluss es sind schulden und nichts
anderes mein letzter satz ein relevanter
teil der bevölkerung meine damen und
herren hat schlicht angst hat
existenzsorgen sie geben aber darauf
keine ausreichenden antworten sie was
ihnen einfällt ist militärisch und das
ist der wahnsinn aufrüstung ist der
wahnsinn war
florian cdu csu muss der nächste gegner
der debatte
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
100 milliarden euro das ist sehr viel
geld das ist kein klacks sondern das
sind schulden die wir aufnehmen die uns
auch in zukunft belasten werden und
deshalb bahn das anstrengende
verhandlungen aber nach dem schlusspfiff
ist schon klar es ist ein
überwältigender sieg geworden für unsere
bundeswehr und dafür an alle beteiligten
mit denen wir über die letzten wochen
verhandeln dürften ein herzliches
vergelt's gott wir haben da gemeinsam
etwas gutes auf den weg gebracht und
persönlich ganz besonderer dank auch an
die staatssekretäre zimmer und hitler
für die wirklich sehr vertrauensvolle
zusammenarbeit
ich bin
ich bin sehr froh dass wir den
bundeskanzler hier unterstützen konnten
tatsächlich das richtige zu tun gegen
den durchaus großen widerstand an
einigen stellen in den eigenen ampel in
einer eigenen reihen der ampelkoalition
und herr bartsch hat dass er gerade auch
eindrucksvoll aufgezeigt es ist zwar
tatsächlich fiel in den letzten jahren
für die bundeswehr getan worden aber wir
wissen auch und wir sind zu der
erkenntnis geworden es war zu wenig und
wir tragen da alle verantwortet wir als
union wir waren nicht stark und kräftig
genug tatsächlich noch mehr zu tun als
wir erreicht haben in den letzten jahren
und liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der
spd sie waren von den letzten 25 jahren
21 jahre an der regierung und deswegen
können sie sich auch nicht aus dieser
verantwortung heraus stellen stehlen und
sie haben ihre haltung im übrigen sehr
eindrucksvoll auch tatsächlich ihre
haltungen unsere haltung zu dem thema
mehr investition in die bundeswehr im
letzten wahlkampf auch zur schau
getragen im wahlkampf verfolgen der
slogan zu lesen das will die cdu teure
aufrüstung von panzer bis zu drohen das
will die spd kostenfreie bildung vom
kita bis zur uni und auf zu lesen war
herr kollege klingen weil das sie zur
distanz auf distanz gehen zum zwei
prozent ziel sie haben auch kritisiert
im wochenblatt die spd der
spd-generalsekretär kritisiert die
forderung gramm kam mowers nach mehr
geld für die bundeswehr die
parteivorsitzende der spd gibt über
twitter zum besten
verteidigungsministerin hkk packt eine
menge zucker in ihrer
regierungserklärung sie fordert dass
zwei prozent ziel und öffentliche
gelöbnis vor dem reichstag applaus bei
der union irritierte stille bei uns
fühlt sich an wie der anfang vom ende
der koalition und er steht setzt noch
einen drauf auch über twitter die
forderung von a kk zur massiven
aufrüstung der bundeswehr mögen donald
trump gefallen mit der spd sind sie
jedenfalls nicht zu realisieren so
tatsächlich die spd bis vor wenigen
monaten
und ja sehr geehrte damen und herren die
union die cdu und die csu wir wollten
und wir wollen die aufrüstung vom panzer
bis zur drohne und wir freuen uns
deshalb dass wir das nun endlich
durchsetzen können und zwar mit fdp mit
spd mit den grünen den weg den wir heute
beschreiten und dafür noch mal ganz
herzlichen dank und
der parteivorsitzender von der spd sie
haben ja jetzt gleich noch die
gelegenheit
diese fehleinschätzung die die spd so
viele jahre vertreten hat einzugestehen
dass wäre wirkliche größe und da setzt
sich auch sie dass sie das auch gleich
tun werden und liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen neben vielen wichtigen
projekten die durch das sondervermögen
endlich realisiert werden können freue
ich mich ganz besonders dass wir nun
endlich auch die dringenden benötigten
ersatz unserer veralteten tornado flotte
auf den weg bringen können denn damit
ist endlich auch die zukunft der
nuklearen teilhabe gesichert die
nukleare teilhabe war und ist das mittel
der abschreckung
verzichtbares rückgrat für unsere
sicherheit europas und das ist ein
starkes zeichen der bündnissolidarität
dass spd und grüne diesen weg zur
sicherung der nuklearen teilhabe mit
gegenseitigen zum schluss ganz
herzlichen dank und frau
bundesministerin lamprecht sie haben
jetzt ein starkes stück arbeit vor sich
sie müssen dieses sondervermögen jetzt
umsetzen dafür wünschen wir ihnen viel
fortüne sie werden unser scharfes auge
bei der umsetzung mit an ihrer seite
wissen herzlichen dank
und damit kommen wir zum nächsten redner
in der debatte zur änderung des
grundgesetzlich wir bleiben aber
inhaltlich auch bei der nächsten debatte
beim bundeswehr sondervermögen da gibt
es dann nämlich um das entsprechende
gesetz lars klingbeil spricht
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen es ist häufig angesprochen
worden in dieser diskussion aber ich
will es auch nochmal sagen der 24
februar markiert einen wendepunkt
unserer geschichte der europäischen
geschichte der globalen geschichte die
welt hat sich verändert am 24 februar
eine friedensordnung wie wir sie in
europa kannten ist durch putins brutalen
angriffs blick über den haufen geworfen
wurden eine weltordnung die wir kennen
gelernt hatten über jahrzehnte in der
wir uns einigermaßen sicher gefühlt
haben die uns stabilität gegeben hat ist
von putins brutalen angriffs krieg über
den haufen geworfen worden und es sind
viele gewissheiten von denen wir uns am
24 februar verabschieden müssten und es
ist richtig und es ist gut dass wir hier
im parlament dass die bundesregierung
das wir als abgeordnete dass wir die
kraft haben auf diese zeitenwende
politische antwort zu geben und das
sondervermögen die 100 milliarden für
die bundeswehr sind eine der antworten
die wir geben auf die zeiten und lieber
florian hahn ich könnte mir das jetzt
einfach machen und auch polemisch
zurückdrehen könnte sagen wenn die union
nicht mitregiert dann werden auf einmal
drohen geschafft ich könnte zurück
antworten dass in dem moment wo die
union nicht mitregiert auf einmal die
bundeswehr gestärkte aber ich will ihnen
sagen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich
finde eine solche debatte ist nicht der
ort für eine solch polemisch
auseinandersetzung ich will etwas
anderes sagen ich bin dankbar dass die
außenministerin der finanzminister die
verteidigungsministerin der
bundeskanzler und die fraktion hier im
parlament inklusive der union dass wir
innerhalb von so kurzer zeit ein weg
gefunden haben und unsere bundeswehr
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten zu
stärken das ist ein wichtiges zeichen
und dafür ein großer dank an alle die
beteiligt
sehr geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
deutschlands rolle hat sich verändert
das sehen wir in diesen tagen wenn wir
sehen wie andere nationen auf uns gucken
wenn andere von uns auch erwarten dass
wir in europa führung übernehmen und das
tut diese bundesregierung aber auch hier
werden sich weitere schritte ableiten
aus der zeitenwende wir müssen uns
fragen wie wir die europäische union
stärken die wir sie geopolitisch stärker
aufstellen wir werden uns
auseinandersetzen müssen mit dem thema
der hungerkatastrophen und wir müssen
antworten geben wir müssen auf globale
krisen antworten geben alles das ist
eine verantwortung die wir als
bundesrepublik deutschland haben und ich
bin dankbar dass die bundesregierung an
vielen stellen klar macht dass sie hier
verantwortung übernimmt der 24 februar
ist ein tag
der ängste in unserer bevölkerung auch
ausschluss zwei flugstunden von berlin
entfernt bricht ein imperialistischer
angriffskrieg aus und ich glaube wir
alle erleben dass in den wahlkreisen in
vielen persönlichen gesprächen dass die
menschen angst haben auch hier im land
vor dem was dort passiert und deswegen
sind diese 100 milliarden auf ein klares
versprechen an unsere eigene bevölkerung
wir werden dafür sorgen dass unser land
jederzeit verteidigt werden kann wir
sorgen für die sicherheit unseres
eigenen landes und deswegen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sind diese 100
milliarden ein wichtiger schritt
die persönliche ausstattung
hat auch etwas mit der wertschätzung für
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten zu tun
ich konnte in den letzten jahren nicht
mehr erklären warum soldatinnen und
soldaten in auslandseinsätze geschickt
wurden hier aus dem parlament warum die
sich nachtsichtgeräte rucksäcke alles
das selbst kauf mussten doch deswegen
sind diese 100 milliarden wichtig das
ist eine wertschätzung für diejenigen
die wir in auslandseinsätze schicken ein
großer respekt für die soldatinnen und
soldaten und wir setzen hier ein klares
zeichen auch des respektes für unsere
truppe und der letzte punkt der letzte
punkt den ich ansprechen will
wenn ich solche debattenbeiträge wie von
herrn bartsch höre dann hat man ja den
eindruck hier findet gerade eine
militarisierung unserer außenpolitik
statt und ich kann nur sagen ich kann
nur sagen was für ein quatsch ich muss
in aller deutlichkeit sagen die
zeitenwende erfordert die zeiten wenn er
fordert mehr diplomatie mehr völkerrecht
mehr multilateralismus mehr einsatz für
den frieden alles das erfordert diese
zeitenwende und für alles das steht
diese bundesregierung aber klar ist auch
wenn jemand wie wladimir putin die
grenzen souveräne grenzen politische
grenzen moralische ethische grenzen
verletzt dann muss unsere bundeswehr
ausgestattet sein um zu helfen und genau
das erfolg mit diesem sondervermögen das
gehört auch zu einer außenpolitik wie
wir sie vorhaben dazu vielen dank
ich schließe die aussprache wir kommen
nur zur abstimmung über den
gesetzentwurf der bundesregierung zur
änderung des grundgesetzes artikel 87a
es liegen mehrere schriftliche erklärung
ring erklärungen nach § 31 unserer
geschäftsordnung vor der
haushaltsausschuss im viel in seiner
beschlussempfehlung auf drucksache 20 91
den gesetzentwurf der bundesregierung
auf drucksache 14 10 in der ausschuss
fassung anzunehmen ich bitte diejenigen
die dem gesetzentwurf in der ausschuss
fassung zustimmen wollen um das
handzeichen
das ist die sind die ampel fraktionen
und die cdu/csu-fraktion wer stimmt
dagegen
die linke und die fdp fraktion sitzt
enthaltungen das nicht der fall dann ist
er gefällt eine enthaltung bei einer
enthaltung vielen dank für den hinweis
der gesetzentwurf ist damit in zweiter
beratung angenommen
kommt unsere dritten beratung und
schlussabstimmung ich weise darauf hin
dass zur annahme des gesetzentwurfs die
mehrheit von zwei dritteln der
mitglieder des deutschen bundestag
erforderlich ist das sind mindestens 4
191 stimmen wir stimmen über diesen
gesetzentwurf namentlich ab sie haben
dafür 20 minuten zeit die ameisen hier
geht es jetzt in dieser abstimmung 1
absatz 3 sätze sind es die in das
grundgesetz noch eingefügt werden sollen
indem dieses sondervermögen hier erlaubt
wird einzurichten in höhe einmalig vor
mir bis zu 100 milliarden euro in dieser
grundgesetzänderung steht dass alle das
nähre ein bundesgesetz regelt und über
dieses bundesgesetz da werden dann die
abgeordneten nun als nächstes
diskutieren das ist der nächste
tagesordnungspunkt das sogenannte
bundeswehr sondervermögens gesetz also
das ist jetzt erst einmal die abstimmung
zum grundgesetz und wir bleiben aber
inhaltlich bei der debatte zum
bundeswehr sondervermögens gesetz und in
diesem gesetzentwurf sind dann nochmal
ist zum beispiel auch noch mal
aufgeführt dass cyber sicherheit nicht
aus diesem sondervermögen finanziert
wird es sollen zwei maßnahmen ergriffen
werden um die cybersicherheit zu stärken
allerdings sollen die aus dem
bundeshaushalt finanziert werden das war
zum beispiel eine diskussion zwischen
den ampel koalition und der
unionsfraktion und die unionsfraktion
wollte eben nicht dass cyber sicherheit
auch aus diesem topf von 100 milliarden
finanziert wird und wie es eben auch
bundestagsvize präsidentin yvonne mag
was gesagt hat braucht ist die union um
eine grundgesetzänderung
hier zu veranlassen
die abgeordneten stimmen in der west
lobby alle darüber ab wie heute schon
mehrmals geübt haben drei stimmen karten
zur verfügung blau weiß und rot für die
zustimmung mit enthaltung oder ablehnung
wer allerdings sich auch etwas gedulden
kann immer der stimmabgabe der kann dann
hier gleich bei der debatte zu diesem
sondervermögen bundeswehr
beiwohnen die eigentlich ohne
unterbrechung hier gleich anschließen
sollte